have time for a few more games
let's play bean counter strike
we've never played before we've never
played before
good luck being counter-strike
what to play i want to play this like
interesting england gambit i think
someone was asking earlier about
uh d5 so i'll play i'll try and play
some normal chess
if white plays london then i can i can
demonstrate what to do against london
oh sure please do blindfold i'll give
you more time
i also have to find my blindfold and
i'll be right back
got to catch you streaming oh oh god
like god to catch you i'll be right back
i have to find my blindfold
okay i was doing oh
opponent being count okay i guess i
do i return the generosity but not too
much okay
i was doing a photo shoot with this uh
yesterday for my most recent
youtube thumbnail on this um
the blindfold simul okay so my f3
signifies we might have a london
but we might not
speech synthesis ready knight f3
knight f7 okay um
volume should be okay
oh no i spilled my tea
i spilled the tea all over the banana
all the bananas like
sad and wet okay
everything's going wrong okay but at
least i have the blindfold
i spilled the tea i'm not even blind yet
okay um i think we're good
okay goodbye to the world
at least the visual world
what oh night i type now f3 i'm at
knight f6
okay so we're playing coffee catch us
bishop g5 oh so it's um
this is kind of a tourist other alexa
i'm so sad please play despacito knight
e4
alexa don't play despacito
here's despacito remix what luis fonsi
daddy yankee featuring justin bieber on
amazon
no i told you not to alexa stop it
did you not understand the word don't
okay at least opponents thinking knight
c3
knight c3 oh that's kind of a newish
move
sort of
i could take the bishop
let's take the bishop oh there's a cool
idea so i'm going to take the bishop
uh knight g5 knight takes g5 and then
knight takes g5 e5 bam
e5 so
i'm attacking the knight with my queen
knight's not defended on g5 expanding in
the center
if knight f3 all i'll keep expanding
with e4
knight f3 yeah
so keeping the initiative
knight d2 okay
do i have some fun i can have some fun
e3
it's a weird it's kind of a weird
sacrifice
and it's not called for
um but the point of e3 i'm trying to
slow down lights development
and then just develop normally
oh but i'm losing i guess i'm losing my
d pawn too
knight takes d5 my pawn
queen h4 check my beautiful pawn
so white has one legal move here
i guess white could resign how many
options do i have
g3 okay that was the main option
now i take on g3 queen takes g3 check
uh-oh my queen
my queen not safe
from being captured
again y only has one legal move
and this is this is a whole point of
playing
e3 earlier oh no oh maybe that was being
counter-strike she takes g3
oh no my queen but oh no you're king
bishop takes g3 okay checkmate
that's a fun little black is victoria
double pawn sacrifice
followed by queen sacrifice
okay sorry if i if i bullied you
but uh thanks for the game knight takes
d5 um
yeah you have to be very very careful
when you're missing the f on like this
bishop d6 um
[Music]
yeah probably g3
g3 is probably the way to go
because this is yeah it's a main three
threat
okay thanks for the game um
i have to clean up this massive spilled
tea
no better way of playing my first game
against you thanks
yeah no that was uh that was an exciting
first game we had
unwanted despacito had a
what was opening this yeah this was like
um what does leachates call this
oh yeah tory attack um
in general bishop g5 is not recommended
if black hasn't committed to e6
because knight e4 is a nice move for uh
for black
bishop f4 is probably the way to go here
h4 is also possible
yeah i'm curious what sockfish thinks of
uh of this move
um oh it's playable
oh wow it's interesting i didn't like it
at first
but give it some time to think it likes
black
but it says i should go for f5
apparently
clamping down
so gotham chess plays a similar line he
i think more plays trumpowski
he made a course on this at some point
or after bishop g5 here
it's a different line because i'm not
committed to this
and then here white plays h4 and there's
some interesting ideas
anyway thanks for the game mean counter
strike thanks for the bits
that was fun maybe it's youtube worthy